Okay-
[INTERRUPTED BY JUMPSCARE, SCREAMS]
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Jolly 3. Now Jolly 3 is a game that I played during the five Five Nights
at Freddy's fan games video which I did last week. If you haven't seen the beginning of this game, go watch that video, it's about
the fourth game I played in, because I'm gonna be picking this up from where I last left off. Unless it dumps me at the beginning of the game again, but I hope it doesn't 'cuz--
Aaahhhhhhhh
Yes. Ahhhhhh.
I only got one crack at this and I didn't do too well so...
We're gonna play this to completion--the entire game in one sitting. Righty-ho.
Yeah, I-I know the whole drill.
OOOoohh (scared)
I didn't know it was gonna be that sudden-
OHH kay okay, alright
*Deep* Wooooaaah
(Let's note that Mark probably didn't read the instructions on the screen, so that's why he panics)
Intercom Guy: "O-Ohh no, it looks like the security system in this facility tripped"
(Tweetie: I see you)
"and the animatronics are part of it."
"*Sigh*  There is not much time, we have to hurry"
"Hold on, I got this"
"Wait what?!"
"Humm, I can't hack the safe. I need to save the port number, and the only way to get that is through ..."
"You"
Mark: Yep, me, I know
Intercom Guy: "Bri-Bring up your phone, I sent you a program."
Mark: Okay thank you.
Intercom Guy: "It's easy."
Mark: Yeah easy, I've tried this before and it didn't go so well
Intercom Guy: "If you use your mouse to click on a box, you'll create a pathway."
"Try it now."
" Keep going."
*Various frantic clicks*
*Beep, ding*
Mark: Hoo.
(Tweetie: I see you)
HEY! WHOA WHOA WHOA
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoahahoh! I don't like that.
Yee...
HOAYY! Hey! Hey! Whoaw... I don't like that at all
Eheheh...
(Tweetie: ????)
*Screech* Nooooo
Stop it, go away I'm busy doing hacking skills
(Tweetie: Random words)
Stop. Stop that. Shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up (x5). I don't have time for you.
Aah!! Hey!! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Hey!
Ouh-oh
Well that's not good... I guess that's just the way things are now
Uh-uh
How many of these do I gotta do?
Eugh Ehuh
*High pitched* BUHUHUHUHUHUH.
Haha... ha.... ahaha...
Oh! I don't like that... Oh I don't like that. I don't know what-
(Tweetie: I see you!)
*Ungodly screech*
*I N H A L E*
*Another one*
UH
(Tweetie: I see you)
And what my what?? I don't know what you're talking about but I don't like it!
(Tweetie: I see you!)
I know you see me! That's precisely the problem!!
Why do I have to do so many of these?
(Tweetie: Stay in my nest[???] for too long.)
Stay with, stay in the whu? What'd you say t- whaAAA??
HOA WHOA WOAH WOAAAH... woooooah eeeasy there....
W-heYY woah! Okay...
[Tweetie Appears]Ayyyy! AHHHHHHHHHHhhhhhhhhhhhh..
*static fades out*
That's hard... *laughs*
Alright! Wow, that is a sack of shit huh?
Intercom Guy: "Alright I... unlocked the doo-"
But this game is so cool! This game is so incredibly well-made.
I'm just... I'm just impressed
Intercom Guy: *quiet cause mark is talking* "You've got to get something and get out
I'm just beyond impressed by it.
Intercom Guy: "Wow this is dark"
(Mark, mocking him) Wrow
Intercom Guy: "[??]... and the only way to get that... is through..."
Mark: Me (Intercom Guy: "you...") Mark: I know. (Intercom Guy: "Quick, bring up your phone")
Okay I'm gonna try not to fuck this one up.
(Tweetie: Hello. I see you...)
Stop? Stop! Just Stop!
(Tweetie: Let's fly to the sky together[?])
STO-
(Tweetie: Let's [play? fly?])
NO! STOP. Stop, stop s- I don't wanna soar on your wings! I- [Animatronic spook]
I- AAAaaahh ffff- *static fades out* Ugh.
*Sighs* That's hard! That's hard! That's really hard! That's really obscenely absurdly hard! *that's what she said.*
Okay? Alright? Okay.
That's a little bit difficult...
Goddayum.
Sack of shit.
Oh, and KEEP the phone down!
Putting the phone on will ACTIVATE Tweetie. OH.
Okay. I see.
(Tweetie: [Don't be shy?])
No, I won't be shy. You're gonna go away? Yes. Okay.
(Tweetie: I sEE you!) Nuuuuuh that's lovely.
Huh?! Uhuhuhuhuhhh!!
Okay, I think I'm gonna get this! I think I'm gonna get it totally fine! I thin- Ohh [adds vibrato]
[No more vibrato] OOOOOOOOOOH
Intercom Guy: "Come on, just one more"
I know, I know one more! I know one more! Dude, you don't need to tell ME, one more! I'm COUNTING them!
Whu???
Control System: "Air Duct: Deactivated"
Whaaaaaaaa???!
Is this good or bad?! I'm gonna assume it's good! I'm gonna assume it's [drops pitch] real good.
Oh I'm gonna assume it's the- ooh.
[Breathy] Hokay... (Intercom: "Alright, so the pin-code is....")
"Nine."
"Seven."
"Two."
"One."
"Seven."
"Nine."
[Beep beep beep]
Okay I got it!
A book! Good! Reading is power!!
Knowledge is your weapon against-guh- Satan! I dunno! I did it!
*Children 'yayying'?*
This job sucks! I'm just gonna come out and say it! This job is a bag of dick! [Singular dick.]
Why do I need to- woah
[Reading on screen text.]
Ohh! Ah!
I don't know if I wanna...
Woah..
Oh, no! Oh, no! Hello?
[Reading on screen text.] *Nervous laugh* And blood! [Continues reading]
...Smells like dildos! ... glitter all over it.
[Continues reading.]
Ahahaaww. That's so nice...
Why are we in the bathrooms? That's not okay.
Why's the bathroom connected to the kitchen?
[Reading on screen text]
Okay.. Alright. Wait, lemme just hump this oven for a little bit here.
*Various grunts*
Okay good! I'm set! I'm ready to go.
So, yeah just lemme hump you for a little bit.
[Hup! Yup!]
Alright I'm all good.
[Reading on screen text]
All right purple guy, whatever you say.
Lemme just, hang on.
[Race car engine]
This ain't right. Nope, somethin' ain't right about this!
Huh. Hup, nope!
Still *laughs* this porridge is too hot! This porridge is too cold!
SOMEBODY TOUCHA MY S P A G H E T
Hello? What's up?
[Continues reading]
Maybe just enough free time to stuff some kids into animatronic suits?
[Reading]
Okay. I'm gon' go... see ya... okay? Where am I goin'?
Ah... Ah this feels wrong.
AaaAAh..
This is weird. Where is this- oh! Hello!
Hello!!
Okay! Just gonna hump this wall! mmMMM,.
Nope. Nothin' there.
Ahhhhh.
Foxy! Are you here? Foxy? No? *Laughs* Just, lemme just stick up this skirt here.
Alright. Oh! Here we go!
[I don't know how to put this sound into words]
That looks ominous!
[High pitched] MMMMMMMMnnnyaAAAHAHAhahaha....
[Reading]
Okay! Alrighty then! Thank you boss!
Glad no one's gonna-
[Narrator speaks, subtitles on screen]
Pff, yeah, okay.
Somethin' tells me that today is gonna be even worse than yesterday!
I just have this- ugh- I just have this obscenely funkalicious feeling that maybe -just maybe!- it's gonna be equally as terrible.
Oh, yeah, okay beat it.
Yeah okay.
O?
Yeah, wha- funny!
That was my inclination! Woah hey! What the- [metal Bonnie appears] HEY!
UHHHHHH??
Okay!
Why?
Did?
That?
Happen?
I am... I guh? UUH
Okay that's not good! Okay we're GOOOOOOOD
Okay the cameras have got, to be pretty better the fu- oh hi okay well you are there and you exist okay that's weird?
[Mark goes from nervous laughter to Goofy]
okay well
Alright you're nearby i'm ready for a gas attack are you my gas is good i think and your ass is gas
oh
i've got my fist ready
all right well that's not good
Okay there's got
To be one of these things that's probably gonna be- Oh they're all there. One of the fans has to be breaking soon!
Oh, boy. Er ai ai..... Try to repair these, I guess.
Okay, we're fine! One of the fans has got to be going soon. Oh, There's- there's two of them there! Yeah, that's uh- uhehehe
HELLO, HELLO
Okay, we're fine! Oh, that's not good! Oh, where is it?! Where is it? Where- who- where- what- why- where- who-
what- and why?
Arh, sh**! Sh**ty dicks! Oh, there you are!
Ah, boy.
Okay, we're fine!
It's gas clock! ughh.....
Okay, we just need to fill the gas back up. I'm gonna repair it first and then i'm gonna fill it- oh that's probably not-
This is goddamn awful! Okay, it's fine though, everything's fine.
YEESH,YEESH
My god, this is fucking insanity!
There's gotta be- there's gotta be- dicking all over my shit!
Okay, if I can just keep my head out of my ass and I should be able to get through this okay.
Ugh, these guys!
okay, but it's fine! I'm already halfway through the night which is far- WURG- RIGHT not looking at you!
I know, I know what you're about- This is just no point! Do you even look at these?!
Without risking death is there?
Okay, we're fine.
We are 100% fine.
OHP- DARG-  PEARGH
Why do I that? Why do I even bother looking? Oh, 4 might go down. Right now, I think 12 and thirty-
WOAH- WRAAAAEEE KAY
All right, that's not good. Oh n-  OH NO, OH NO- OH TWelve, thirteen, eleven. Surprised it was eleven. Who would've thought?
eagh, okay. Got to refill and repair.
Okay, we're fine! we're fine. We're almost through this! We're almost through this GODDAMN NIGHT!
Hello?- NO, WHY? WHY DID I DO THAT?! WHY DID I WANT TO LOOK INTO BONNIE'S EYES? Oh, so tenderly, they're so enticing....
what have you got for me straight ahead is it gonna be straight ahead
Yeah, you know it is.
Why are these testing chambers, by the way? What kind of horrible animatronic place needs testing chambers?
I guess this is where they're all made isn't it?
come on i
Don't want to i don't want to do that oh i got the code right here passcode is
nine two six seven three one
okay
hey
that was easy
Well that was easy huh what do you do staples button
I don't know baby
love burns eternal
i don't know you're getting kind of philosophical here i'm not in the mood for that
are you talking about lover forever cuz my love for you is forever
i'm okay with that
okay i don't understand any of the words that you're saying but i'm assuming that i can time travel now
is that what i'm to assume
okay all right bye i'm gonna pass out now
Guess i'm done i guess i'm done
Life is shit love is never gonna happen for me oh
I can't wait to go to freddy today that's so wonderful
Yes, when we get there here's how things are gonna go i plan every detail of my life daddy has to get his
Work done and while i'm doing that i call myself daddy and you should to
i'll buy you some tokens
So you can play in the arcade
after i'm done we can order pizza and watch the show does that sound like a good plan or what
does daddy make good plans or what yeah well well should we get going yes get in the car
Daddy needs to go to work
all right
Okay all right daddy needs to go to a super special secret workplace here we are are you coming silly
yeah one second
okay
that's not something a responsible parent would do
don't get in
Why dad please stay in the car zoey i beg you
Haaaaaaaaaaaaa?!
Aaaahh?!
What the hell?
What the hell? (x2)
What the hell? (x3)
Jeezum, tryin' to play game here and tryin' to listen to the goddamn tapes.
I don't know why I keep looking at that.
I don't know why the demon soul of Chica's here to kill me.
Everything is horrible and I hate it...
Why is it-- Why am I looking there?
I don't know...
Ugh... and apparently--
BluuuuOHOHOHO
Hi, bye... gas time.
Okay, apparently there's some kinda code that's hidden around everywhere?
And I don't know what that's about but okay.
Ah, jeez... everything in this just a goddamn nightmare all the time as a--
BLRHRHRHR
Alright, okay, alright, well...
I dunn-- I dunno. I dunno. I got the fear burps.
So one of these fans is-- phbrbrbrbrbrbbrbrbrb
hrhrhrhrhrhrh
Alright, okay...
Ahhhhhhh
Aren't you cute? The way you boop and ya beep all over the place. Don't do that to me.
What's going on here?
HA-- I was heyprehahe! [Wut?]
I definitely, definitely 100%... didn't
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh b-- ah boy.
I'm-- I didn't do that. Why-- di-- I have no idea what happened
Oh we're back, we're in trouble. Ohh we're in trouble.
No, we're fine...
AHHH WE'RE NOT FINE
for one goddamn second and i could get my hand out of my ass and i could figure out a way out of this
Stupid shit we're okay oh seven my break oh?
Five also a culprit a one oh? (I dont know.)
shit
So you got, to put it down is that what you gotta do oh shit oh shit
Oh, shit oh shit oh shit oh fuck oh fuck
there it is yeah fuck nah fuck
Nooooooaaaaah! (who the heckle deckle is Noah, Mark?)
Okay we're fine oh?
god i need to stop being on that goddamn menu so that i can stop thinking that everything is gonna fucking break! (loud and bemoaning) Ooooh!
Last hour! We got this. I just need to not let anything get in our way. (Loud and bemoaning oh #2) OoOoooH!
My god. This is just a panic. God, that's just a straight-up panic from start to finish.
Okay, but we're fine.
Woah! Heeey >:0! I don't like the way you got a slack-jaw. Oh no oh, no, oh no, oh nooooAAAAAh.
You're all happening at once and i don't like it
Ugh
You're done! Yes!
All right! I did it! I am the man.
I am the man with the plan.
This is gonna be the last area to go into so is it gonna be like the last area that i can go to or is there gonna
Be some other secret. Some other secret bullshit here- I just scratched my forehead
Okay
HUAGHHHHHH
*static*
What!? WHAT!? W H A T ! ? *sirens in the back ground*
Uhhhh?
You want to run that by me again? Oh this is bad...
Girl:"What brings you here?" Mark: Uh... y'know...
"To this... harmonious place of ours."
Harmonious?
"It's... an unusual time to see visitors."
Inquisitors? I- *??? sounds*
Visitors?
"I didn't even get to clean this place up."
Oh.
Baby, it's alright! You don't need to impress- *baby cuts in* oooh
"DId you come here to see someone?"
Ugh...?
Baby, you don't need t- *baby cuts in* right.
"Or are you here for something else?"
Oh, you know. Your good looks-  *Baby stop interrupting him D:*
"Have you came here for evidence?"
"You came here... to relive the past."
Ah well I don't know about that???
"But the past doesn't want to be revisited."
Didn't you just say?
"Especially that..."
"Particular...past."
Didn't you just say-
"It has... bad things attached to it."
"You don't care what other people think."
"You don't care..."
"What they feel."
"All you care about... is the fame that you'll get." (Mark is Thirsty™)
"The money that you will indulge in."
"It's fascinating..."
"How money can make you do things."
"They never thought"
"We do"
*exhales demonically*
"If you haven't noticed yet"
"People who come here, DONT come out." *mark makes a scared uncertain Ahh sound* "And it stays that way."
*Another unnerved Ah*
"Although..I have to give you credit. It's fascinating how you've managed though three nights here."
Oh yeah.
"This will be your last."
Umm!
*Sirens blaring*
WOAH! OH! OH! OH! UH!?
Lift body up! Put body down! Lift up! Lift up! I'm lifting! Oh I'm lifting!
Woah! Oh Im lifting so liftily! I've never lifted my ass this hard in my life- Oooh god. Oh God oh God. :'''D
I don't know if i'm doing anything? I'm trying real hard?
uH- EY EH EY EY OKAY
ALRIGHT! IM REALLY TRYING. REALLY TRYING. REALLY TRYING.
OOOOH WOAH!
THERE WE GO THERE WE GO THERE WE GO THERE WE GO
Okay! Okay! Okay! Alright!
I think i just gotta do this- aAAAHHRRRHH
OH OH HO HO HO OH HO HOHO (merry christmas)
*Monkey sounds*
OH NO. NO NO NO!
NO NO!
YEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE(T)
I CANT
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH HOO HOO *INCREASING PITCH* (Okay i have school someone else sub the rest.)
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead AAUUH
yep, i'm dead did he want oh
What did you want me to do? I was lifting up my body and I was slamming it down I
was doing about as good as I could have slammed all right let's try this again if I have to go through that goddamn
speech again I'm gonna be pissed off
[Screen reads:"Try mashing"] Hh really just try mashing okay
I am mashingI'm really mashing it guys I'm really mashing it whew oh
god my hands... oh they're cramping up...oh
Boy, here comes death
Here comes the death cramp... oh boy here comes the death cramp
oh my god
Ha i'm about, to i'm about, to start sweating that was just, so much intense mashing...good god
Intercom Guy: OHH! I thought you were dead! The [smasher?] has been running for 30 minutes!
*#Shook*
30 [Original SS said: old man heads] whole minutes huh? Oh my god...
Well I did that my job's done. I quit!
Also I quit did I mention that I quit did I mention how I quit
Because I feel like that's an important detail that's being overlooked here I quit and quit...uh oh
Kid you you're not supposed to leave
Zoey, Zoey, what ever told you Zoey
Welp...here I go...aahhh...
This is not good oh
This is
No, this is not good
wow
Zoey this is um... oh
That's not good they have no heads
They have no heads okay well let's go to the place where i think i'm supposed to go well it's not
Here it's not the bathroom, okay
hm,
*weird yell* woahoh
wooahh
[Reads Screen Text]
woah
(#Shook&Disturbed)
That's fucked up okay I guess I'm still working for some reason I'm still working here! Yay!? Yeah I got a job and a paycheck
Yeah, I'm so happy *High Pitched* Yay!
Well fuck you, fuck you
*Phone Ringing*
oh shit, shit
okay thanks boss yeah boss from the past phone guy i guess talking about the original five nights of freddie's place
whatever it doesn't matter, alright
That is a scary face, okay so everything is gonna be horrible this night I don't even know
*weird animal noises of nervous confusion*
okay everything's fine everything's fine
I don't know if this is gonna be like the last night or something
But I have a funny feeling that it might be because there's only one other hall to do it and also why am I still
going in here? Why would that asshole not tell me that there was an active animatronic in the hall
that was gonna kidnap me and send me down the crusher...
Yeah, I don't like it i don't like any of it but I gotta do it I guess for some fucking reason oh shit shit
shit
Welp shit. fuck off fucking god fuck me fuck me where's it there it is oh ah fuck me
I .. Am I dead?
I'm dead okay alright fucking come on are you kidding with that bullshit
My god how could I even win, Come on you sacks of- *cuts himself off* Whiat
nope you're not gonna give me like that because I know your tricks and I'm too smart for you and
Even if I wasn't very smart I'd still be too smart for you because you're a big dumb animatronic
and I will...what I don't know what that was at all
okay
That's the thing that can happen?
Apparently we're just gonna pretend like everything is hunky-dory and I'm not worried about it oh boy
What is that oh boy yep that's what I thought it was okay can I please click on these oh?
FU- Come on! No you can't do that that's not fair?
Ahh
That's not fair!
god fuck you uh... fuck off
You can't do that that's not fairrrrr
Ah that's so unfair you're such a sack of shit
Okay, doing all right so far we managed to survive something and so long as we duck
Immediately whenever we see chica like that you sack of shit then everything's gonna be fine even if we're about
to repair a fan it's more important ah ha ahhkay hi hi year *mumbles to self*
mmbrroi ohahaha i thought that was an animatronic i mean technically i guess it was the ghost of an animatronic
But, i'm not here to split hairs i'm just here to survive
what is why why did that what ah oi
what the fuck!!
What the fu-gk where did whyyy
What!?
what a load of shit i just died for no reason
Rah aghhh
ok, well this sucks fucking dick god fucking fuck you just fucking repair it
oh come on!
fucking fat donkey dicks
Fucking cockaroni and cheese come on come on come on come on come on come on!
What's happening why i don't know what's happening oh it's that fucking alarm and the goddamn
braughh
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine huuugh
last hour last hour- nno!
god damn it god damn it god damn it *softer* god damn it god damn it god damn it
goddamah goddamuh, ah god damn ah alright ten seconds oh
we got easy peasy good easy boiah easy peasy
easy peasy and just like that
ayyy!
we did it last room i think
maybe maybe not but there might be the last room
All right only one way to find out is there an active animatronic in the hall probably probably definitely
Okay here we go we're going into it and we're doing okay we're not dead yet we're just saying something because we-
"alright what have we learned last night? uhh..
that touching any electrical device is dangerous and triggers the facility security system"
"but that's what we're here for right?"
yeah sure okay "No pain no gain..."
"All right try finding another electric safe" why do i always have to do this and why are there so many safes around here
Why's everything locked up in a safe i mean i understand security and everything but one is everything have to be individual- woahh hahah..
*electronic voice*  "security system activated"
Ah.. that's not good is it
*distanct strange voice* "birthday girl!"
ehh?
*guy who's been guiding through all this* "wait, what?"
"I can't get into it,
damn firewall is blocking the path... quick! open up your phone!"
I don't wanna "all right i'm gonna need your disable the firewall so i can hack my way into the safe" I don't wanna
"to do that you need a virus i can't see me the buyer software-" wha "-through your phone cuz well
It's a virus." that doesn't make any sense to me what
"I'm gonna send you lines of code, add those codes into the phone-" what "- to write the program"
whaa? " once this program is executed it will disable the facility's firewall-"
okAY! "-and I will be able to act the safe (WHAT?) so we can all go home... got it?"
*uncertain* yeah
"alright here's the first line" woagh
got it! "keep going.."
oh god aughh
that doesn't sound good oh wait i see that holy shit
Okay wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa uh? Uh? Uh, uh i'm dead i'm dead
i'm not a little bear! (he actually said that its not an error)
what did i do oh fuck what the fuck ah i'm super fucked i'm super fucked oi! ahhah, hello
How the fuck are you sp-ehehet Jesus ..
a goddamn typing puzzle
well if you're bad at typing you're gonna be bad at this i guess there was no way
To like flash to get them away so i guess it's just a purely
skill based thing oh wow what was that book wait book whoa
what, the fuck
ahhh
wait may appear and the cameras do not switch cameras and wait until it ohh
Aah!
metal foxy oh boy
oh boy
alright well alright then that would have been helpful a little bit ago oh
Don't use your phone to make maxi go back ok that makes sense that's easy enough
yep it's a birthday girl
my girl easy
easy zz i got this nah shut up shut up shut the fuck up shut the fuck up
hyeah! chyeah chyeah chyeah
ahh
I'm right here shut up go back go back go back
To where you came from you sack of poopy you big ol sack oh you're about to find out what my fists main
purpose is! and it's not happy
wheezy (where is he??)
No, no, no
No, no, no, go back go back go back go back go back go back go back go back go back go back
Thank you go back please go back go back, to where you came from please please
*strange animatronics voice* "where are you?"
i'm right here yah douche
*guide guy* "come on dude one more."
one more ok easy enough easy enough easy up initiate dot adder ssl
*electronic voice* "??? (I think it's firewall) deactivated"
Okay i did it i think I did it and I think i diaod it (he said did weirdly)
o-oh
*guide guy* "huhh, thought we were done for-" woah
"all right you should be able to open the safe now." okay..
great "alright so the pin code is..." AH HUH ?
"four, eight, two, one, four, four "
Mm-hmm! ooooooih
cassettes wait are these the cassettes you were talking about that i got already
oh boy, oh no
oh No, is there more i don't even know if it's gonna be able to possible do another night of that.
oh boy this don't (sounded like he said this stone though haha) look good oh hello
alright woah
ahi whhahahat
okay all right oh excuse me i'm very sneaky very extremely sneaky
I don't know what I'm blaghalalalgh, oh.
oh
blaghelelughguhg (fish noises)
Okay here we go i guess
o-oh, o- h, o-oh, oh! augh!
Ahh That's no good okay so i somehow got a sneak by all this bullshit
oh come on!
fucking asshole god damn it all right i'll wait then i'll wait and vibrate
bleleleleleh (more fish noises)
got it, nailed it, nailing it, nailed it nailed it!
perfect o-oh
o-oh well this ain't good
huh, hmmm
mmmm!
woh
okay i'll get in
okay
i'm in i'm in a truck why did i want to get in the truck what was the point of that
what was the point of getting in a truck and there can't possibly be another night here
To bad!
whaa
I don't-  I I don't agree i just don't agree i don't agree I- I- I
no
no, you asshole, no!
No, noooo
oh hello? hi?
ahhh that sucks okay well that sucks oh boy oh
Boy, oh this is how this nights gonna go oh i'm super happy about this i'm all smiles all day baby all smiles all day
Yeah, come on well I've lost i can't find it
It's it doesn't exist there's no there's there's not there was none i went, to every fucking camera
god damn it
*sighs*
This is gonna be a bitch augh sometimes i wonder why why why why would anybody do this waa ha no
Okay you i'm right there right there i'm right there i'm, so right there
Yes, yes i am i am, sam i am sam i am just give me over there repair it fill it i am good, oh
Halfway there god damn it why do i do this job
Why do i do this i don't need to do this it's not like a fucking internship or anything like that
one, wh, What in the world would cause me to do this i have no idea
found you, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on
ahhggh come on!
No, no i had it no! oh i'm fucked aren't I? augh fuck you?
not, now okay well this is gonna be fine okay you're gone perfect oh..
great
great of course right and please let it just be something nearby
Nope of course not, no, i'm fucked i'm fucked of course i'm fucked there it is god fucking damn it you make it impossible
you make it fucking impossible
the fucking hell
it's the very last one i hit i was on one of them that was oh my god you're
Fucking my dick you're fucking my dick fuck you there's no point in trying to preempt
anything here there's no point there's exactly zero purpose
ah well i'm fucked i'm fucked if that happens god if that happens bef- agh it's just, it there's no point
if that happens
When there's an animatronic in the room there's nothing i can do there's just nothing i can do it's death one way or the other
there's just nothing i can do
well im fucked
can't see shit mmm
No, yep, wow okay yeah see that's? fuir
That's fair that's
fair yeah that's solely fair yeah
there's definitely something that i could have done to avoid that i'm sitting here waiting for death why okay well
death is gonna come no matter what i guess
yep, there it is okay of course
haughh
Maybe, i'm bringing up my console too much maybe that's like triggering more stuff because it was it was surprisingly calm there when i was
just
sitting and waiting for death so
Honestly who knows it might be a good strategy if i'm like in the last hour and i just feel like i need to ah
Dive, for the finish so what's the point of these lights you'd think there would be some greater purpose to it but i mean why
have the lights at all you know what i mean and there's a keypad obviously for some kind of a secret here but
I don't know what it is
Ho-hoh! I'm w-
no
What the fuck no, way not
How, no, way if that had killed me after the fact i would have been
unbelievably pissed off and i'm not
So let's do this
That sack of shit was not going to beat me "whoa dude did you know about this
there's a passageway right leading to another facility right next to this building that's the choice located at the storage room
maybe there's an unactivated animatronic there
it's worth a try"
yeah
worth a try "look, I know that you're the one doing all the work and I
Know that you're tired"
"with all this bullcrap, but think of all what you get if you do this, all the money all the
recognition
you're tired of living the same boring life every day and that's why you did this in the first place
right?" no, no no
oh
ohhhhh
well howdilidicldido
oh okay
So there's gonna be a second update i mean this is jolly three chapter one okay!
i'm a little pissed off at how tough that last level was but
besides all that it was still a really
really good five nights at freddy's fan game i can't fault them for making it challenging
Because once i got into it and once i really understood the strategy it became a lot easier but it was still very
difficult but that's not a bad thing because a lot of what five nights at freddy's has always been is about a really difficult task
and
things just getting
exponentially harder as the time you go on
but this was a really fun one i am glad that i went through this game and i'm glad that i
uh, I
Played it to completion and i'm glad that i was able to do this for you guys because there are some games like this out
there that maybe five nights at freddy's fan games but there's still really really well done so i want
To see ooo
yeah!
Hi why is that flickering that's weird. maxie,
George, jolly
er Jolly you don't look so good, i don't like the look of you, anton?
oh okay alright that's okay
augh metal freddy hello hi
metal bonnie hello
metal chica and metal foxy chica you were the biggest bitch alright let's see this
bargh wait what the wait hang on
speed it up i want to speed it up oh, come on
alright fine
roar
roar roar
ugh, augh, that's a bad one barg okay rahr rahr rahr rahr excellent love it
transcripts oh
Okay well no thanks bts oh coming soon custom night
custom night
custom night oh that was oh god oh oh
augh
ladies night oh boy you know what i'm okay
I am
okay
So that was jolly
three i'm not gonna bother with doing the 2020 modes i'm now good at the game and i probably could with enough
Perseverance but i just don't feel like i need to prove anything at this point so thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know he fought down in the comments below if you want to play this game for yourself
I'll leave a link in the description and the second chapter this game should be coming out at some point the other game that i'm
debating playing is day shift at freddy's
because it just seems funny and silly and i'm not one hundred percent sure that i wouldn't enjoy it very much
(Let's note that Mark probably didn't read the instructions on the screen, so that's why he panics) But I might do that in a stream setting more than anything else so thank you everybody so much for watching and as always
I'll see you, in the next video!(11!!1!1!!!)
BUH BYE !!